this is what it's all about right here
take a look at the story from the Daily
Mail
Bud Light boycott I'll drink to that
pole finds most Americans back
Anheuser-Busch snub over its tie up with
Dylan Mulvaney and say corporations give
transgender rights too much attention
take a look at this do you support or
oppose the boycott of Anheuser-Busch 37
strongly support 17
somewhat support now here's the best
part
you then have uh the like the not sure
segment of people is the smallest
you've got 18 strongly opposing it 12
somewhat opposing it so you you you're
looking at the majority of people are
saying outright we are in favor of this
boycott and that says a lot yep how many
people is uh it was a survey of 1 000
people 1 000 adults from Rasmussen and
it found that 54 of people uh supported
it so Rasputin actually tends to be
decently accurate surprising uh I would
say surprisingly not the right word
um in in this regard we take a look at
like a lot of the uh election data and
Rasmussen is is fairly close in terms of
getting the the actual results right so
I would agree with this you know and and
just real quick to uh shout out Jesse
Kelly when he said the first time his
neighbors ever asked him about politics
was because of Bud Light so this
absolutely lines up can I just point out
one flaw in the poll and this is not a
knock on Rasmussen but don't you have to
ask beer drinkers because this is asking
adults it's a thousand adults and that's
the problem we always have with these
political polls that come out when they
try to push people one way or another
they say we pulled a thousand adults
about Trump well adults aren't
registered voters and registered voters
aren't likely voters and it's not the
best sampling it's not no but I disagree
uh I don't drink but I'm a beer buyer we
we typically would have a beer stocked
here we haven't done a little bit but we
would go out to different breweries in
the area and we'd pick up cases of beer
because we have guests and we have
people humans like beer you know so I
think it's fine you know just because I
think about think of this way too let's
say I don't know what percentage of
people don't drink beer at all right
they're going to go out with their
friends still and they're going to be
like hey don't buy that they're going to
support the boycott well some of us
don't drink light beer at all
I tend to not take polls too seriously
unless they're it like huge but like a
thousand people I'm just kind of like eh
and you're right maybe none of them
drink or ever did and ever will so like
I don't know and I want to make not make
the mistake of wanting to believe a poll
that I like just because it's something
an outcome that I like
um well here's the problem with the
boycott that we found at Breitbart from
day one you're not going to drink Bud
Light oh well let's look at these other
brands oh they're all also owned by
Anheuser-Busch so in Bev yeah yeah it's
it's very very hard to find an
alternative if you like that now there
are alternatives out there but I think
it brought home to people how few big
companies are actually in this market
and that in turn brought home
the fact that the political agenda that
companies are often indulging in has
become so Universal because there are so
many Industries we have this amount of
concentrated commercial power that they
can change the culture so easily with
one ad campaign now I don't know if they
succeeded in this one there's a backlash
but from their perspective it might
actually be a successful marketing
campaign because they've raised brand
awareness to new heights people are
talking about their beer I don't think
so maybe maybe but if unless they come
out with a with an apology then it's
just very very negative I mean you got
Rhonda Sanders coming out today I think
it was today and he said I'm not going
to buy their beer anymore why would I
like it's just cascading and normally
these stories they don't last three
weeks can we get him to ban that beer at
Disney World then we can put this all in
one story that's what does it not the
prison like maybe they need a new prison
next to what is it was it called
something Creek OH Greedy Creek whatever
really I said they should call the
prison the Epcot Correctional Center
that's great I I initially thought that
this was going to be received as a an
attack on Dylan and so I was kind of
against the idea of boycotting because I
was like people are going to take it as
an attack on Dylan they're going to take
it as as uh you know the right being you
know mean-spirited Etc and I was like
this isn't going to go well it's going
to look bad and I'm happy to say that it
looks like I'm I'm wrong I think that
the the general uh population doesn't
feel like you're they're bullying
dillian Dylan I think they feel like the
the problem is with bud and I think that
you know that that's showing in you know
in the polls and stuff for me I think my
conscience is cleared in that we talk
about it as in as if the the beer
company got a guy that targets children
as his main audience to sponsor beer
which I don't care if you're gay or
trans or whatever your sexuality or or
gender or whatever I really don't if
you're a good person it's if things like
this misalignment where little kids are
getting fed beer ads or their favorite
influencer is selling beer and they see
them drinking it in the tub and they're
like nine like that that's where I think
they made a huge mistake and I do not
fault Dylan although uh for that aspect
of it although I don't like that he
without maybe even realizing it is has
kids as his little audience and is
selling beer but I mean you know he's
he's in a meteoroic rise state right now
and probably doesn't have a lot of
advisors around him that he could trust
Ali London has done some digging and
found various posts from Don Mulvaney
lying and so the whole thing in my
opinion is is a bit and and and more
evidence backs it up uh apparently there
was an old post Dylan Mulvaney has
deleted some of these old posts and I
think the reason is Dylan tried doing
like made a post about being trans and
having trouble getting acting work but
then later made a coming out as trans
also said on the Rosie O'Donnell podcast
whatever show that is
that that just started they just came
out publicly for the first time and just
started taking hormones in this one
video and then Ollie was like but if you
go back you can see that Dylan Mulvaney
was was I'm sorry in the podcast I think
domovany says they were taking the uh uh
estrogen and other pills but then on
Tick Tock there's a video where Dylan
claims they just started what I've
actually heard from some transgender
individuals they don't believe that
Dylan's actually taking any estrogen at
all based on you know Dylan Mulvaney's
body and appearance they think it's it's
not true he's too bony I don't know I
don't know about what their reasoning is
but the the thing I pointed out uh the
other day is that someone with like
someone with body dysmorphia
gender dysphoria or anorexia or whatever
is not going to make a video to 10
million people pointing to the thing
that triggers their dysphoria or
dysmorphia like Dylan Mulvaney does yeah
he's so light-hearted and joyful about
that he's a woman no no says he's a
woman like no no that is a man that is a
man so my point is this he's like look
I'm a girl no no no no no you'd be like
what that's not what I'm saying when
Dylan Mulvaney made the video pointing
to his dick and said women have bulges
look at it look at it look at it people
with dysphoria don't do that because it
gives them dread and anxiety that's kind
of the point so this is what I was this
is what I was told by a trans woman she
said that Dylan Mulvaney doing that
immediately revealed that this person is
not trans because that is like the
antithesis of why someone would consider
getting surgery to remove that body part
the idea that someone would be driven
mentally to the point where they want to
amputate their genitals and then to have
someone like Del Mulvaney point to it on
camera to 10 million people that's the
antithesis of of being trans that's what
was told to me I'm not trans I don't
know I could be wrong I'm just saying I
don't think it makes sense and so
ultimately what it comes down to is I
hate talking about the individual but
this is a bigger story in how the
algorithm is ruining the minds of
children and it's like you add on all
the all the creepy nonsense they're
jamming down children's throats young
girls getting Tourette Syndrome young
girls getting weird surgeries and lip
fillers and now you want them getting
drunk man they are really trying to hurt
kids
and I think the real issue here for
conservatives is the fact that all this
is about kids and that's obscured by the
left deliberately and by the White House
extremely deliberately yeah no it's just
I was watching the White House Press
briefing a day or two ago and they were
talking about how
the Republican governors in the red
states are passing all these anti-lgbt
laws 400 laws or something like that and
they
lump in the LGB with the T and they make
the T all about transgenderism as
opposed to kids and having kids exposed
to certain things I think
it's depressing actually to watch all
this rhetoric get thrown around because
none of it gives any credit to
conservatives for just caring about kids
rightly or wrongly I mean if you agree
or disagree or whatever but you have to
at least recognize that the motivation
is to protect children and yet it's
being described in exactly the opposite
way that conservatives are the ones and
I like the word use bullying kids that's
the word that they're using very
effectively that Republicans and
conservatives and people who are against
all this are the bullies there there are
a lot of stories coming out from D
transitioners that are really really
horrifying and you know tweeted one and
it got deleted and I guess because the
individual posted it started getting too
much attention but you see a lot of
these stories from males and females
talking about how it was a huge mistake
they were confused kids going through
puberty and they were lied to and now
their lives are forever ruined the crazy
thing to me is when you get someone
who's say 15 years old and then they
sterilize that person they're not going
to know what they've lost for a for a
while and I can't imagine I just
couldn't imagine I've seen more than
enough stories and heard from more than
enough people who find out rather
accidentally that they're sterile
infertile or otherwise and it's always
seen as like a very devastating story
like they can't have kids there's always
always these tropes about uh how about
the movie Dogma the woman says that her
husband left her because she found out
she couldn't have kids and he didn't
want to be with someone who couldn't
that's like a portrait is a very deeply
negative thing but now all of these
young people they're going to grow up
and they're going to be like yeah I
can't have kids and in fact for many of
these young people someone like jazz
Jennings they can't actually even
experience sexual sex at all
uh the the situation the more I learn
details about jazz Jennings the more
appalling it sounds the the
the mother talking about the the uh
what's it called
whatever the expander is or whatever
dilator dilator that's what yeah oh
there's so much more too because here's
the thing you know conservatives don't
watch that show I am just
and I think now people are starting to
realize like maybe we should watch that
because when this clip went viral
showing the mother say that she
basically is like abusing Jazz it's a
crazy clip she says she like hold her
down and force this thing into a wound
to force the wound to stop healing it's
like it's crazy I think then it's Ryan
too yeah and and where are we as a
society to be like this has to stop
this is the crazy thing to me I I'm
thinking right now about I'm still
thinking about what we were just talking
about I'm happy to move on if you guys
want to but it's about bullying you
brought guys brought up bullying because
you're saying like the left is claiming
that people the the conservative people
are bullying the transgender Community
but like we're here talking about no
it's about selling like twisting kids up
when they're young that's the problem
but I'm looking at Matt Walsh's Twitter
from April 17th and it says the tweet
this is to win with this Bud Light
situation is when they publicly
apologize for promoting transgenderism
which that's not about her it has
nothing to do with kids he is actually
saying he's angry that the transgender
the concept of transgenderism is being
promoted to kids he didn't say that he
just said in general now I'm wondering
if a 20 year old guy rocks a musician
got a Bud Light contract would anyone
even make a noise about it
if his if his fans were 15 year olds I
don't think anyone would even care
because he's just a regular time but
it's Dylan Mulvaney with a dress on so
now it's getting a lot of attention I I
absolutely would take issue with a 20
year old musician selling beer 21 but I
or or any any I I don't care if the
guy's 60 years old for some reason his
audience is 15 I think it's a bad thing
the issue is how how notable is that
individual in the culture War for us to
even notice it's happening just because
I didn't know the thing it doesn't mean
I'm okay with it and this is an argument
that left uses all the time where
they're like if you're so concerned
about that what about this and it's like
wow thank you for bringing that to my
attention I am also appalled by that
they do this thing where they're like
drag queen story our concert are so mad
about this but I don't see them
complaining about children beauty
pageants and it's like what it's like 20
years ago me and my friends were smack
talking child booty Pages as being gross
we'll still do it today they're just not
that big they're not that prominent
they're not in the National conversation
but I got no problem saying those things
are nasty and I got no problem saying
little boys should be going to Hooters
as like an appropriate place to get
thinner but that being said as much as
the left likes making that argument I'm
like dude women having boobs at a
restaurant just having women there is
very very different from having Kink
shows for children so I want to bend
this metaphor a little if a 24 year old
musician with fans that are younger got
a Bud Light contract would anyone blink
an eye yes but the thing is you can't
quantify the age of the fans you just
don't know we can with Tick Tock you
know we did this we had this debate a
little bit over cigarettes right they
canceled Joe Camel
about I don't know 15 years ago because
the cartoon image of the camel was
thought to appeal the children and so
the
maker of those cigarettes I can't
remember which company made camel makes
Campbell it's just camel they they got
rid of Joe Camel and for that reason
because even though it wasn't appearing
in children's media kids were seeing the
Joe Camel and thinking okay there's this
cartoon that they associate with
cigarettes but you know let's be real
like James Bond was a bigger influence
in getting kids to smoke than Joe Camel
was if I was 20 I was seriously I was an
actor in my early 20s I mean I'm still
an actor but I was in Hollywood for a
lot of that and if I'd booked a Bud
Light commercial at the age of 25 and
people went nuts on me because some of
my fans were 16 and 17. that's I would
be out of my mind pissed off at them
yeah I'm over 21 man I'm selling beer
right but that's not it Dylan Mulvaney
is on Tick Tock with 11 million
followers and outside of Dylan Mulvaney
the average Tick-Tock user is 20 years
old that means if you were to take every
single person using the platform which
includes adults it still skews young and
Dylan Mulvaney's audience at the very
least is underage and and should not be
drinking yeah well let's be real they
Bud Light Anheuser-Busch they all know
kids who are 89 drinking and my personal
opinions of drinking age should be 18
and people shouldn't drink either way
but if you're an adult you should be
allowed to the point is delmovie's
audience audience isn't 20 years old
that's the tick tock average Dylan
mulvania's audience skews much lower
than that and is probably closer to 15.
you know and even then I wouldn't I
wouldn't blame the guy for having a
young audience and I don't think it's
that big it's that he dressed up as a
little girl Eloise and did a video a
month or so ago pretending to be a
little girl that's what the Benny sells
beer the next month remember the guy who
drew who was the the trans little girl
that old guy let me pull this thing up
oh God you know the whole drag queen
Story Hour is also interesting because
the whole drag phenomenon has changed as
well
there is video of Donald Trump sitting
on the couch I can't remember what talk
show it was but next to Dame Edna I
don't know if you remember Dame Edna you
know uh famous drag queen here you go
here you go everybody and it was it was
just kind of ordinary like Rudy Giuliani
dressing in drag on Saturday Night Live
and again it's about adults and it's
it's not a show meant for kids but but
the
the stripteases and the the Kink shows I
think are again when kids are coming to
that are being brought to that that's
what people are objecting to not drag in
general right and and uh interestingly
even some Democrats don't want drag for
anybody thinks eight percent we were we
were talking about this the other day
most Americans 52 think drag should just
be for adults a large portion are unsure
and then it's like 24 think anyone
should be able to see a drag show even a
child but those are of course Democrats
and a small portion of Independence yeah
we had the story from a while ago this
is a a guy who lives as a six-year-old
girl
like sure whatever man I do your thing
in fact I got a Bud Light contract I'd
be pissed because he's he's dressing as
a six-year-old I I actually would not
really yeah no I do I don't care like
remember Jack Daniels uh uh people were
talking about floating the idea of
boycotting Jack Daniels because they
sponsored RuPaul drags right drag race
nobody cares
like hey look what they did and everyone
was like yeah
a wave of outrage when people found out
about that because RuPaul's Drag Race is
a bunch of adults right and then you
also had uh Coors Light did a Pride
Commercial some people pointed out that
even Yingling has had as a Pride
Commercial before nobody cares there's
also a distinction from trans to drag
exactly there's you know the issue is I
think twofold the first is that Dylan
Mulvaney is I I I think mocking women
intentionally making it making it and
trans people and targeting children but
also let's just be real Dylan Mulvaney
is very annoying to people it's and I'm
trying to be mean when I say that I'm
saying people describe Donuts Nails on a
chalkboard this this I like him what
he's like a theater guy I would have
went to school what I see is with Dylan
Mulvaney I see Tick Tock exploiting
someone who is clearly unwell like the
the Bud Light commercial he was just
like shaking back and forth and doing
these weird Motions like something's
wrong and normally if we saw someone
like on The Price is Right rolling on
the floor screaming at the top of their
lungs I'm not kidding watch the prices
Right video of domovany dilemovanny more
than one occasion screams the top of his
lungs like and normally if you saw
someone do that you'd be like I think
this person is in need of some kind of
help he was on Ellen DeGeneres this dude
has clearly got some kind of
narcissistic personality disorder they
are feeding this stuff to two kids that
is why I'm upset now obviously Matt
Walsh is upset with gender ideology
being pushed but I've said it before and
I'll say it again that means a lot of
people be mad and see whatever he wants
to see but I've said this when he talks
about Dylan Mulvaney Dylan Mulvaney does
not represent trans people right not not
in the slightest it is this weird
mockery it it is it's almost trans face
it's like this dude singing about his
bulge is like come on man
like there I I think the left it goes
way overboard with a whole bunch of this
stuff I think they lose it when they
support people like Dylan Mulvaney but
there is a fair point to be said that
there are many trans people who use
bathrooms and no one says anything like
no one knows me and no one exactly
exactly so when you see Dylan Mulvaney
putting on this performance which makes
trans people look like Psychopaths to
the point where it's easy to attack the
entirety of all transgender people it's
like okay that that's why Dylan Mulvaney
is a problem so I'll put it this way and
always always to to open our good friend
Blair white in this one but it's because
Blair white is our friend that I want to
bring this up
Blair White's super awesome and not not
doing any of this weird crazy garbage
nonsense there's a whole bunch of
individuals Sarah Higdon we had in the
show totally rational reasonable people
who aren't rolling on the ground
screaming and then Don Mulvaney goes on
camera and just becomes a caricature of
the most insane depiction of whatever
this is enough to the point where it's
it's the primary focus of when can
service trying to say like hey this is
our problem with gender ideology right
how much of that is baiting the
conservatives I mean they've
successfully now involved the whole
conservative movement in reacting and
outrage to a Tick-Tock character how
much of it is a successful marketing
Ploy or even a political plan to rile up
conservatives using the most egregious
example let's say of one category of
entertainment and then we go for it and
then Gavin Newsom piles on and everybody
else piles on and they talk about
Republicans bullying people and suddenly
the younger voters are convinced that
Republicans are awful people who don't
understand social media and don't
understand them that was a problem with
conservatives when I was like in 20 2005
when I was you know Hallmark liberal
they were so easy to upset if I made fun
of Jesus I could rile up so predictable
they were just so overly sensitive
reactionary just so easy to take control
of those people and it is something
people need to work on one of the
reasons people might be as sensitive
about this issue in particular and Tick
Tock is just a degree to which parents
watch their kids on devices during the
pandemic and parents are hypersensitive
right now to everything that's being fed
to kids on social media there's a huge
problem right now of school refusal kids
who were on their devices for two years
and now have to go back to school and
just simply refuse to sit at a desk and
listen to a teacher and participate in
class and so the devices have become
much more a part of kids everyday
reality and I think that might also be
driving some of this not necessarily the
transgender stuff but you've got this
person who is influencing kids now
they're representing an alcoholic
beverage or whatever whatever and
parents are
freaked out maybe a little more than
usual because it agreed to which they've
seen their kids lives taken over by
devices in social media I agree I have
to imagine and some people watching
maybe maybe even have experienced this
one day you ask your kid like what are
you looking at and they're like oh don't
Mulvaney and they're like oh and they
look and it's Dylan Mulvaney drinking
beer and being like Bud Light oh and
they're like Whoa man like I don't maybe
you shouldn't be on this app if it's if
it's some some adult guy dressed like a
little girl trying to convince you to
start drinking booze something about
that just doesn't seem right I think a
lot of parents are that's probably why
this reached a level of regular
Americans are saying they support a
boycott of Anheuser-Busch
Nike I I I think another good example of
why this is the case is Nike because
people did get mad that Don Mulvaney was
sponsored by Nike but that one didn't
really go anywhere either because that
wasn't targeting children it was just
kind of insulting women but you know the
women didn't get pissed off enough
going after kids and telling them to
drink and basically insulting March
Madness and the core demographic of just
like middle-aged white dudes who drink
beer really really bad play on this one
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time